good afternoon everybody
I know we have some serious business
ahead of us today but as you know
sometimes a girl just want to have fun
come on come on come on
come on I'm trying I'm trying guys
um but in all seriousness this afternoon
we are celebrating a truly historic
moment for marriage equality and so I
brought a friend with me who is an icon
really doesn't need any introduction but
we are thrilled that she is here we are
honored to have her here with us today
on this important day Cindy Lauper who
has been advocating as many of you know
for lgbtqi plus Community for decades
particularly to end youth homelessness
Cindy will be performing this afternoon
and I thought I'd invite her to in front
of all of you all today to say a few
words and Cindy thank you so much for
coming
hi I just um
I just want to tell you I came here
because
I wanted to say thank you to President
Biden speaker Pelosi vice president
Harris and all the Advocates and his
team
for for once all families
mine and a lot of my friends and people
you know sometimes your neighbors
we can rest easy tonight because our
families are validated and because now
we're allowed to love who we love which
sounds odd to say
but Americans can now love who we love
and
bless Joe Biden and all the people that
worked on this for allowing people not
to worry and their children not to worry
about their future thank you and thank
you for being supportive and hey I will
sing out to you thank you very much
okay thank you so much Cindy for coming
again this is an extremely
uh historic day a proud day for me and
so many of us here at the White House
and so many Americans just across the
country and uh we truly will be looking
forward to Cindy performing on the south
lawn today I know we don't have a lot of
time and so we'll go straight to
questions see thanks uh I've seen the
news
the president received campaign
donations
for him many Department Democrats and
some Republicans as well but will the
president return that donation or does
he call on all politicians who got uh
campaign donations that may have come
from customer money to return those
funds so look I'm covered here by the
Hatch Act limited on what I can say and
anything that's connected to political
contributions uh from here I I would
have to refer you to the DNC president's
opinion no uh he want those people who
no you asked me two questions you asked
me about will he return the donations
and then you ask me about his opinion
I'm answering the first part which is
I'm covered by the Hatch Act from here
I'm limited to what I can say and I just
can't talk to political contributions or
anything related to that I cannot speak
about it from here his opinion though I
I just is just just cannot speak to this
uh from here even his opinion even his
thoughts about the contributions
donations I cannot speak from it from
about this from here
I am covered by the hot check which I'm
happy to say over and over again because
we believe in the rule of law here
next week title 42 is coming true how is
the uh the administration preparing for
that and uh what more uh is the
president prepared to do to stop
[Music]
so what we're doing uh to need to
prepare uh we are asking Congress as you
all know for uh the resources we've been
coordinating with leaders Across the
Western Hemisphere as you all know we've
reported on meetings that we've had and
actions that we have taken we've got
anti-smuggling operations with me with
Mexico Guatemala up and running and so
that's been incredibly critical as well
we're working to combat misinformation
from from Smugglers and as we as was the
the case before title 42 and remain the
case after it individuals who attempt to
cross the border unlawfully and don't
have a legal basis to remain will be
subject to removal and will and will
certainly have more in the coming days
but look you know you've heard this say
this before and we put the question to
Congress and what what are they going to
do here Republicans are asking uh you
know how are we going to secure the
Border I've listed out on ways that
we've tried and worked to work on that
but we're also wanting to do this on a
bipartisan way we're talking about you
know where the president's about to sign
this marriage equality bill which was
done in a bipartisan way so we know how
to do that we know how to work with
Republicans Republicans know how to work
with us so why don't they work with us
on this particular issue that is
important to uh important to Americans
across the country and uh and we're
asking for them to to join us on this on
this issue as well
uh the president said he's convinced
inflation you know will continue to go
down but we have of course seen some
unexpected spikes over the last uh past
year so just to be clear is the White
House confident that inflation has in
fact peaked so look
um I know the president uh was asked
this question he said he also said I you
know I'm not able to predict uh this as
well uh in his comments today so look
one of the things that I want to say is
like today is a welcome news to American
families uh just across the country the
annual consumer pricing deck has fallen
for the last five months and so that's
important to note and last week we
learned from the producer price index
PPI Rose at at its slowest annual rate
since May 2021 and near-term consumer
inflation expectations fall fell so we
have more work to do as we know the
president has been doing a lot of work
on getting that gas prices down and we
have seen uh seeing that fall about a
dollar and 75 cents millions of
Americans are going to save about 100
bucks per year on health insurance
because of the work that the president's
done because of the inflation reduction
act and so look we know there's more
work to do and we're going to continue
to do that but again you know the
president said we're not able to predict
but we have seen some good signs from
the data CPI PPI and so we're just going
to continue to do the work to make sure
that we do what we can to lower costs
for American families I mentioned today
is obviously a big day for this
Administration for the president I'm
wondering if he's shared with you any of
you know his personal Reflections and
the public with them as he's sort of
evolved on this issue and for you
personally you are the first to openly
gay press secretary what is this so
personally this is a big day for me but
not just me there are many colleagues
that I work with here who are allies who
are also part of the community who are
very incredibly proud we're going to see
about two to three thousand people out
in the South lawn who have worked we're
talking about activists who have worked
on this issue for decades and people who
are truly affected uh by what is
happening today to the signing of this
bill I was just with the president as he
was going through his remarks and the
thing that I remember was 10 years ago
you all many of you all have played this
on your networks today when he was on on
um on Meet the Press and he said
something that really no other National
elected official was saying at the time
that marriage is a proposition and it's
about you know who you love but if you
were going I'm going to mess up his
quote but who you love but also about if
you're going to be loyal to that person
and I think that's important and that is
something that again he said 10 years
ago when many people were not saying
that many people in his position and he
has always been an ally I think I speak
for many of us at the White House today
that we could not be prouder to be
working for this Administration to be
working for this particular president
and to be working on all the issues that
are going to change Americans lives and
as we have seen historic historic
legislation over the last 22 months
agreed aside from the arrest of Sam
Beckman free what actions can you take
to protect people from the collapse of
the crypto market so we've taken we've
certainly we have this Administration
has consistently
urged Congress to take action to address
regulatory gaps posed by digital assets
and support legislative efforts to enact
crypto legislation to better protect
American consumers just last month
secretary yellin in fact called on
Congress to move quickly to fill the
regulatory gaps that's a quote that she
said herself and the Administration has
has identified what those gaps look like
but again we have urged this is
something for Congress to do we have
urged Congress to take action and we'll
continue to do that Jake was a little
unclear on this yesterday there's the
president plan to travel to Africa next
year so look um don't have anything to
preview at this time uh as you said Jake
spoke to this just uh just yesterday 24
hours ago uh and there will be an
announcement about a broad-based uh
commitment to travel to co to the
continent in 2023 as it relates to the
president as it relates to the vice
president as it relates to Cabinet
secretaries as well but we're just not
going to get ahead of that announcement
uh but again don't have anything to
preview today but we'll we'll have
something for you soon okay I'm just
following up on the 1042 question there
is a bipartisan framework in the United
States Senate there is a vehicle moving
right around the time of the title 41 or
title 42 potential deadline is the
administration all in behind trying to
get something done in this very tight
period of time do they feel like to tell
a cinema framework isn't quite there yet
how are you looking so good look we're
encouraged by the bipartisan uh
conversations happening on immigration
reform currently in Congress as you know
on the president's first day in the in
the White House and his administration
he put forth a comprehensive immigration
reform because he understood how
important uh this uh this issue was
protections for dreamers that's what was
in that that legislation that he put
forth it pull forward cutting down this
Asylum backlog modernizing our outdated
immigration system and so we're we're
going to let the process play out I'm
not going to get ahead of it as you know
there's negotiations happening on this
framework that's being led by a Senator
Senator Cinema in Tillis and so but
again we're encouraged by it and you
know the president put that out there on
day one that this is important that we
needed to get this done and then uh on
another topic just real quick there's
been some positive smoke signals on
Omnibus negotiations where they're going
um do you feel like the process is
getting closer to the end game you guys
want at this point or too early to tell
we've been very clear on this Phil as
you know I think you've asked me this
question almost every time you've been
in the briefing room
I know you love you love appropriation I
understand that
um and our view is this and I I'm
repeating myself here uh as as we've
talked about this over the past couple
of weeks since certainly since the
midterm elections which is there was a
bipartisan uh agreement that was done
last year on this and we believe that it
could be done again this year and
there's enough time to get this done
this is not a par partisan issue we're
talking about bipartisan issues here
when it when we talk about the American
people National Security right we talk
about public health public education all
key issues that matter for all Americans
across the across the country and so
again we are just going to continue to
encourage Congress to act and to get
this done
Jim thank you uh does President Biden
support or oppose legislation
legislation that is sold in Congress to
create a 911 style commission to
investigate the U.S response to the
covet pandemic what is the White House
position on this so I think this has
been asked before I think during uh
Jen's tenure I don't have anything more
to add or more to look into on this I
would have to go back to the team and
see if our position has changed but
nothing new for you it was the position
no I'm just saying I I know that this
has come up I just don't have anything
new to add or to go back and ask and to
see where we are on that so whether you
but does the administration support it I
just I just answered your question I
said I know this has come up in the past
but I don't know if we've changed our
position I have to go back to see
exactly where we are on that particular
question
okay is there a sense today with the
president signing the respect for
marriage act that that makes it settled
in America or is there still some
concern that based on some of the
comments from Justice Thomas or the
potential for other litigation that this
could still be an issue that would be
explored in the U.S so I think a couple
of things there look this is an
important civil rights accomplishment
that achieved that was achieved in a
bicarma and a bipartisan way and it got
that support right and when the
president signs it today it will bill on
General it will build on generations of
civil rights advocacy uh that that
brought us to this historic moment so
that's important uh to note but look we
understand in spite of this import
legislation it is also true that there
are extremist uh conservatives who
appear bent on taking away fundamental
rights including marriage equality this
bill provides an important measure of
security and state stability for lgbtqi
Plus families but their children should
should
see or should also will also get the the
attack right as we know
um sadly and their legal tax on marriage
equality will continue to persist and so
there is absolutely more work to be done
on the lgbtqi for the lgbtqi community
and so you'll hear from the president
he'll talk about that the work that
needs to continue to get done and so
that is something that he understands
this is again an important step forward
but we also have to pass the equality
act that is also something that the
president has called on from the
beginning of his administration and will
continue to do but we cannot ignore how
important uh today is how important this
moment is and how it actually Builds on
all the work that has been done across
uh the past couple of decades thanks
Karina um today the president talked
about his economic agenda
um you know saying that it was part of
the reason why we're seeing inflation uh
easing does he also credit the fact and
the rate hikes as a reason why we're
seeing inflation is I'm just not going
to respond to any actions that the FED
has taken they are independent we are
never going to comment about that they
we believe they have the best monetary
policies to deal with inflation but not
going to comment on the actions that
they have taken or the actions that
they're going to take the president look
as we have no the president has taken uh
has an economic policy economic plans
that we have seen him execute over the
past 20 plus months that has shown to
have been effective in where we are with
our economy right now to have shown that
we've been able to grow or create I
should say a 10 point 10.5 million jobs
that matter
especially after what happened when he
walked into the administration with the
pandemic with what was happening with
the economy the bipartisan
infrastructure legislation creating jobs
good paying jobs and so that will
continue he can he feels as you heard
from him today day this morning that we
need to continue to make sure that we
build an economy from the bottom out and
middle out and don't that we don't leave
anyone behind and so that's what he's
going to continue to focus on to say
that he thinks in large part it's
because of his agenda well we have said
we have said uh the what we are seeing
today with the economy being as strong
as it is uh and and what we have been
able to do with job creation uh and uh
we believe that a lot of that is because
of his economic policies now as it
relates to inflation and what we've been
seeing with inflation of course the
president has made that his top number
one top economic priority and making
sure that we bring costs down and that's
why he's taking actions on on gas prices
that's why he's he signed the inflation
reduction act because he wants to make
sure that we're lowering cost for the
American American families but we have
to remember what the president inherited
here when he walked into this
Administration we were dealing with the
economy that struggling we were dealing
with Americans who were losing jobs and
so he was able to turn that around and
that's what he means about his Economic
Policy thanks Corrine I I president was
about to enact a landmark piece of civil
rights legislation now some of you can
speak to the concerns that some have
expressed that what's actually in the
bill could be read is something that
codifies discrimination there's a
section here that speaks to the ability
of non-profit religious organizations
faith-based social agencies educational
institutions employees of those
organizations to deny Services
accommodations facilities Goods
advantages privileges to gay couples so
how is that not codifying discrimination
so a couple of things let's let's walk
through what's in the piece of
legislation that the president's signing
in a few minutes it codifies Federal
recognition of same-sex marriages that
matters technically the Defense of
Marriage Act from the 1990s was still on
the books but essentially dormant
because of the uh oberger fell
um decision this repeals Doma and
ensures Federal recognition of same-sex
marriages it requires states to
recognize same-sex and Inter interracial
marriages performed in other states I.E
if oberger fell or loving Falls and you
get married married in Massachusetts
Alabama still has to honor the marriage
meaning if your husband wife gets sick
and Alabama hospital would still be
required to let you see them that
matters for so many millions of
Americans across the country I know
there's questions about religious
liberty and so we believe that you know
we believe that the rfma contains strong
protections for houses of worship and
religious non-profits and this question
was well litigated throughout the
legislative process where it passed with
both chambers of bipartisan support and
I think that matters right bicarmal
bipartisan support was had for this
piece of legislation and so look as the
president said 10 years ago as I
mentioned it comes down to a fundamental
question of who would you love who do
you love and will you be loyal to that
person this law ensures that it realized
for all person and that's why so many
Faith leaders and religious Traditions
have advocated and support for this bill
so it has gotten support in a bipartisan
way across the country in Congress
during this time right where uh you know
where people say we can't get things
done here we have this piece of
legislation that has gone bipartisan to
support okay
um things green on immigration How
concerned is the administration that
there will be this unprecedented surge
of migrants try to come across the
border once title 42 goes away so look
um as you note
um uh as I know you guys are all
tracking the secretary mayorkas is in El
Paso today and he's assessing operations
and he's speaking to the workforce down
there he's also meeting with local
officials who have been and who have
been incredibly important Partners as we
rebuild our Asylum system the Department
of Homeland Security is working to
quickly decompress what we're seeing in
the El Paso area for example and safety
and efficiently screen and process
migrants to place them in Immigration
enforcement proceeding over the last 18
months DHS has deployed enhanced Autumn
automated processing system automated
service surveillance Towers rescue
beacons and additional Personnel to the
sector in addition to that CBP has
deployed additional agents support the
sector uh that's on top of the mobile
processing units medical screening
personnel and nearly 1 000 border patrol
processing coordinate coordinators DHS
already had deployed in the area so look
look this is something again the first
day of the president's Administration he
put forth a uh a comprehensive
Immigration Reform Bill because he
understands how important this is we
have taken action we have we have given
the Department of Homeland Security
historic funding to deal with this very
issue and so we're going to continue to
monitor this uh like as I mentioned my
Arcus was down at the at in El Paso to
talk to local officials to who have been
great partners with us and so again
we're going to do the work we're going
to be prepared and we're going to make
sure we have a a Humane process moving
forward
there are some lawmakers who are arguing
that title 42 should be extended somehow
does the White House believe that's even
possible so look you know we are
required by court order uh to lift title
42 by December 21st that is the court
order that we have been given and
Department of Justice is going to lead
that effort and what happens next so I'm
not going to get ahead of that but again
you know this is a court order that we
are following here
um I wonder if the White House is
worried that the inflation data which
came out this morning was leaked there
was big market movement about two
minutes before it's it came out and I'm
just wondering how the White House has
viewed that yeah I've seen those that
reporting look you know I I think we
think that it's it's being a little bit
um
uh
how do I say it's uh you know I think
there's too much too much weight being
put into that uh and uh you know and how
the market may have moved in a minor way
uh you know I don't I don't really have
much more to add to that but I have seen
the reports on it and again I think it's
just being a little bit uh we're looking
into it a little bit too much I think
White House and treasure are you looking
into it at all or are you just not
worried about it okay look I think that
um
look when it I can tell you this there
were no leaks from here I can tell you
for definitively uh or at least I'm not
any aware of any leaks and I know they
were very strict security protocols to
prevent leaks but I think again people
may be reading a little bit too much
into this into some of the minor Market
movements and so anything more I would I
would refer you to the Department of
Labor
um just above what Steve asked um
we understand how the legislation was
framed and will be signed by the
president do you anticipate that this
Administration will go back to the
Democrats will go back and try to clean
up the language in the legislation so it
does not codify uh discrimination look
what we're saying to you today is that
this
this piece of legislation was done in a
bipartisan bicarmal way and it will make
a difference for millions of Americans
across the country and we're going to
celebrate this moment we are going to
celebrate the activists and the families
who have worked very hard
the last couple of decades to make this
happen and that is what hap that is
what's important and that's what you're
going to hear from this president today
is there more work to do absolutely
there's always more work to do and
you'll hear directly from the president
certainly not going to get ahead of him
at this time but again this is an
important moment a historic moment that
we uh that we should not forget what it
means to many many millions of Americans
across the country we follow up on that
so he'll sign that today and you say
there's more work to do or is he
endorsing additional work to try and I
don't have anything to preview from here
as I said there are extreme extreme
conservatives who are going to continue
to attack this who are want to take away
fundamental rights we saw what happened
just in June with the Dobbs decision and
so we you should take that very very
seriously but again this is an important
day and we're going to celebrate this
day with thousands of people who will be
standing or sitting in the south on the
south lawn and hearing from Cindy Lauper
and the president and the first lady and
the vice president it's a really it's a
really good it's a really good day it's
a very good day
and then you just get One Direction okay
thanks Karina uh there are reports that
the administration is considering
slashing the number of Cubans Haitians
and nicaraguans arriving at the border
who would be eligible for Asylum uh
while creating new narrow Pathways for
those uh Nationals to apply for some
legal status here
um the concern is this was a a model
that was actually designed by Stephen
Miller in the prior Administration so is
it true that the administration is
considering this new structure for these
foreign Nationals so look I I was asked
this question last week and I we don't
have anything new to preview or to
discuss at this time about any policy
changes or any policy announcement so
don't have anything to add but I I have
heard those reportings and I did speak
to this last week as well
a foreign policy question I was
wondering uh there have been clashes at
the border between India and China and
the pensions are pretty high between the
two countries is this something the
administration is concerned about so
look we are glad to hear that both sides
appear to have quickly uh disengage from
the clashes we're closely monitoring the
situation we encourage India and China
to utilize existing bilateral channels
to discuss disputed boundaries again we
are we're glad to see that there's been
some disengagement on the clashes at
this time
yeah I think you are I'm allowed your
colleague to go ahead of it thank you um
with Republicans about to take control
of the house are there additional
economic policies the president wants to
implement in the next couple of months
look the president has always been clear
he is working for the American American
people American families to do
everything that he can to lower cost as
we're talking about the inflation that
we're currently seeing as being one of
his number one economic uh uh plans here
and then you know as you've seen him act
on gas prices as you've seen him act on
inflation reduction act we're going to
see early next year the real effects of
the inflation reduction act as it
relates to Bringing Down health care
costs energy costs so the president's
never going to stop he's going to
continue to do that work he's always you
know always happy to work with
Republicans and looking to reach across
the aisle as we've done with the
bipartis infrastructure legislation as
he's done with the chips and science act
in order to create jobs and and bring
jobs back Manufacturing entering jobs
back to companies back to the country
and so we're going to continue to do
that that never that will never end or
never stop
is the White House whipping against
Senator Bernie Sanders War Powers
Resolution and set for a vote in the
Senate tonight uh look we've spoken to
this uh before I don't have anything
much more to add I know my colleagues
actually was asked this question last
week don't have anything more to really
uh
discuss or lean into on this Bernie
Sanders just said that he's dealing with
White House opposition to it right now
so just hoping for a confirmation of
what all is going on there uh so look uh
I'll say this we're in touch with
members of Congress uh on this thanks to
our diplomacy which remains uh ongoing
and delicate the violence over nearly
nine months has effectively stopped as
we have seen during this Administration
the situation is still fragile and our
diplomatic efforts are ongoing so we
want to make sure that this is not
impacted in the people of Yemen do not
suffer or that any of the progress we
have made is overturned again I really
don't want to get ahead of the progress
we continue to work with Congress on
this we're having the conversations I
just don't want to get ahead of that
sounds like you might veto that if it
comes I'm just I'm just not going to
make a prediction I'm certainly not
going to make a prediction of what the
president is going to do is not going to
do we're having conversations with the
members of Congress and I will leave it
there thanks everybody
thanks everyone